[Música]
leer es un placer
en eso seguramente en la mayoría de los
que están aquí estarán de acuerdo
conmigo
claro no siempre
hay lecturas que no se enojan que nos
preocupan que nos hacen releer y releer
hay contenidos con los que estamos de
acuerdo y otros no pero en general
disfrutamos los textos sobre todo la
narrativa crecimos arrollados con
cuentos nos gusta el ritmo
los disfrutamos tanto que el olor es
parte del disfrute de un libro
pero hoy
hoy según datos de la unesco uno de cada
seis
y seres humanos del planeta
en algunos contextos no puede leer y
escribir como ustedes y yo y en otros
contextos son dos
y en otros son tres y son mujeres
desafortunadamente mujeres que no pueden
leer y escribir a sus hijos enseñarles a
leer leerles leerles en la noche un
cuento
eso
me hizo pensar
en que hacer que se puede hacer si hemos
dicho tanto sobre la lectura hemos hecho
tanto hemos investigado hemos generado
políticas la unesco por ejemplo ha
generado una política pública
junto con varios gobiernos con los
estados-nación miembros de la unesco de
incentivar la educación inicial
de que en el preescolar y antes no en
las guarderías haya textos para que los
niños los toquen los manipulen jueguen
con ellos se les lea en voz alta pero no
todos los niños pueden ir a la escuela
y qué más podemos hacer si hemos dicho
tanto
y
pensando pensando
seguí intentando construir ideas como
investigadora
y fue un día como muchas ocasiones he
ido a comunidades en situación de
pobreza donde la escuela no siempre es
la escuela que desearíamos donde haya
escuelas distintas a la orilla del surco
y ahí me encontré con una niña que
cuidaba de tres hermanos menores
esa niña
me dijo entre risas y entre seria
maestra si tú me enseñas a leer al rico
yo te enseño a pescar el ricky era su
hermano menor de año y medio que iba
junto con ella a la escuela
sus otras dos hermanas ya sabían leer y
escribir por la presión de ella
por llevarlas a la escuela por esa
responsabilidad que no le tocaba pero la
asumía no solo de llevarlas a la escuela
sino de pescar camarones de río para
luego con esos camarones de río pescar
los peces con los que los iba a
alimentar es el intercambio eso me movió
el corazón
y dije bueno qué más podemos hacer qué
más se puede hacer qué más podemos decir
y hoy
quiero compartirles todo eso que hemos
pensado no solo yo otros investigadores
otros educadores
padres de familia también
hay que acercar los textos a las niñas y
niños desde temprano igual que esta niña
tiene la clara idea aunque tenga tan
corta edad de que hay que comenzar
temprano con la lectura hay que comenzar
temprano si hay que comenzar temprano
pero no con prácticas constreñidas que
hacen a los niños odiar la lectura no
cuando el maestro les dice si sigue
exportando te mal
basal te va a tocar leer hay que generar
otras prácticas no esas de castigo hay
que enseñarlos ese disfrute de la
lectura porque al leer de semana desde
temprano
vamos escuchando esas formas de decir
propias de lo escrito esas formas que
vamos a usar para escribir
esas formas esa semántica que nos va a
ir haciendo entender el mundo entender
al otro
y entendernos a nosotros mismos
es muy importante comenzar temprano como
esta niña tenía esa clara hipótesis
muchos padres de familia al igual que
esta niña creen que hay que comenzar
temprano y por lo menos que aprendan a
leer y escribir los niños que aprendan
el rudimentos de la aritmética para que
sepan hacer cuentas y defender su
salario
pero no todos lo logran la escuela no
siempre la escuela que desearíamos para
estos contextos a veces la escuela para
los pobres en lugar de que sea la más
rica es la más pobre
ustedes están viendo la imagen es es una
escuela esa escuela funciona no crean
que es el ciclo pasado
esa escuela funciona en la orilla del
surco en muchas comunidades donde van
familias jornaleras a cortar chile
qué hacer entonces ya dijimos que es
importante porque nos enseña las formas
de decir propias de lo escrito también a
los niños pequeños les ayuda al
desarrollo cognitivo la atención la
memoria el lenguaje a veces también los
niños no sólo aprenden porque la escuela
no es la más adecuada aunque el maestro
tenga interés y buenas intenciones no
hay condiciones para aprender pero en
ocasiones también porque la lengua que
hablan los niños y niñas no es la lengua
del aula
y aquí les contaré otra anécdota
que ahora se convierte en anécdota pero
es terrible si uno le escucha es
terrible pero nos enseña y justo quiero
compartir eso no esas enseñanzas a una
niña le dice una entrevistadora que dice
ahí
qué crees que dice ahí
qué crees que dice ahí insistía
la niña ante tanta insistencia toma el
libro y hace esto
no dice nada esa fue la respuesta de la
niña no dice nada a veces el lenguaje
el lenguaje que usamos en el aula los
maestros de estos niños y niñas no es el
más adecuado no pueden participar de las
actividades porque no entienden las
consignas porque no entienden lo que la
cultura escolar ha construido así leer
en voz alta como ustedes seguramente
disfrutaron de esas prácticas acercar a
los niños a la cultura escrita es parte
de la construcción de ciudadanía es
parte de la construcción del acceso al
derecho a la educación si logramos eso
los tomadores de decisiones los que
hacen política pública los maestros los
que pueden incidir para que las mujeres
adultas aprendan a leer y escribir
seguramente tendremos un mundo mejor y
así al igual que enrique hoy puede
disfrutar el olor de los libros
sigamos disfrutándolo todos antes de que
cambie tanto el mundo
[Aplausos]